Jill Adams a former U.S army medic who
is also a recovering addict currently
works as a security guard at a local
College however Jill has a secret side
business she steals drugs from the
research lab and sells them on the side
her life takes a sudden turn when she
finishes her shift and goes to pick up
her two children Noah and Matilda from
their grandmother Doris as they drive
home their car suddenly loses power
causing them to swerve and collide with
another car before plunging into a
nearby lake Panic ensues as the vehicle
sinks and Jill watches helplessly as
Matilda struggles to survive but just
when it seems like all hope is lost a
police officer arrives and manages to
revive Matilda however their relief is
short-lived as they soon discover that
something strange is happening the
officer reveals that everything that
relies on electricity is malfunctioning
they Rush Matilda to the hospital where
they encounter a surprising Revelation
the patients who were previously in
comas have miraculously woken up the
hospital staff is baffled by this
unprecedented phenomenon feeling both
confused and anxious Jill Noah and Doris
return home but sleep eludes them Noah
claims to see shooting stars which Jill
explains are actually malfunctioning
satellites the next day as Jill heads to
work she notices that the entire
neighborhood is wide awake at the
college she attends a meeting with Dr
Murphy a psychiatrist who explains the
dire situation everyone has seemingly
lost the ability to fall asleep the
ramifications of sleep deprivation Loom
over them and everyone is desperate for
a solution however there is one
exception an elderly woman who can still
sleep she is currently being studied at
a military base known as The Hub where
researchers hope to find a cure for this
Affliction realizing that Matilda
possesses the same ability Jill becomes
fearful that her daughter will be taken
away for experimentation as well she
rushes home fearing the worst only to
discover that Matilda is at church at
the church the pastor delivers a sermon
referring to Matilda as a Beacon of Hope
however some churchgoers see her as a
potential sacrifice Jill and Noah arrive
just in time to prevent harm from coming
to Matilda but the other church-goers
apart from Doris and the pastor are
reluctant to Let Her Go a chaotic scene
unfolds when an officer shoots and kills
a doctor who arrived with Jill causing
panic among the people in the midst of
the chaos Doris manages to hide Matilda
from view realizing they are in danger
Jill Matilda and Noah flee into the
nearby Woods desperation fuels their
actions as they search for shelter and
safety they stumble upon a garage and
Jill takes a risk entering the premises
while leaving Noah and Matilda outside
stealthily avoiding two men Jill finds a
car and secures it as their means of
Escape she retrieves Noah and Matilda
and as they huddle together in the car
Noah suggests that they take Matilda to
the hub a decision that Jill reluctantly
agrees to knowing it may be their only
chance for a solution to their Sleepless
predicament Jill Noah and Matilda arrive
at a library seeking refuge and a
momentary respite from their arduous
journey in an attempt to ensure their
safety Jill decides to teach Matilda how
to handle a gun hoping it will provide
them with a sense of security however
Matilda refuses unwilling to engage in
such violence in a moment of frustration
and Desperation Jill fires the gun
accidentally inadvertently shooting Noah
the shock and guilt Ripple through Jill
as she realizes the consequences of her
impulsive action Noah undeterred by the
mishap manages to find a map within the
library recognizing its significance he
eagerly brings it to Jill together they
study the map piecing together the
fragments of information it holds and
discovering a possible route to The Hub
the military base where a cure may be
found their Journey takes an unexpected
turn when an escaped prisoner seizes
their car with Matilda still inside Jill
and Noah find themselves at the mercy of
other prisoners who pose a threat to
their safety just as hope seems to fade
the man who stole their car Dodge
intervenes and saves them from harm
grateful for Dodge's unexpected
assistance they form an unlikely
Alliance continuing their arduous Trek
they stumble upon the wreckage of a
plane Noah and Dodge scavenge the debris
searching for any useful items that
might Aid their Quest meanwhile
recognizing the dire circumstances they
face Jill takes on the responsibility of
teaching Matilda how to drive with her
unique ability to stay awake Matilda
becomes their only hope for survival in
a world plagued by Eternal wakefulness
as they navigate the treacherous roads
their group falls under attack by a band
of desperate individuals fueled by fear
and determination Jill Matilda Noah and
Dodge managed to narrowly escape the
clutches of their assailants driving
away with their lives intact finally
after enduring countless trials they
reached their destination The Hub Dodge
recognizing the significance of their
mission offers to stay behind ensuring
their safe arrival Jill acknowledging
his selflessness insists that he takes
their car into Parts giving him a chance
at his own survival with a heavy heart
Jill bids farewell to her children and
Ventures into the Hub alone aware of the
risks she disguises herself as a lab
worker infiltrating the facility in
search of The Other Woman Who possesses
the ability to sleep upon finding her
Jill is confronted with a disheartening
sight the woman is Gravely ill her
condition deteriorating rapidly she
reveals that she should have succumbed
to sleep deprivation months ago
overwhelmed by despair Jill is convinced
that a cure does not exist faced with
the devastating reality she implores the
woman to take Matilda under her Wing
serving as a surrogate mother figure in
a chance encounter Jill is spotted by Dr
Murphy and to conceal her true
intentions she feigns a desire to help
desperate for answers she queries Murphy
about the existence of a cure tour to
which he responds that six days have
passed without any breakthrough and the
lab workers rely on a temporary brain
function enhancing drug that causes
severe neurological damage in the midst
of her turmoil Jill's encounter with the
army forces her to reveal the truth
about Matilda's ability overwhelmed with
emotion Matilda tearfully admits her
unique gift she can still sleep the
following day arrives and Matilda eager
to contribute approaches the doctor and
expresses her willingness to help
intrigued by Matilda's unique ability to
sleep the doctor believes she may hold
the key to unraveling the mystery as
Matilda explores the facility her gaze
falls upon an ape that has been
subjected to experiments to her surprise
the ape remains awake even when exposed
to anesthetic gas the doctor reveals
that chimpanzees due to their close
biological connection to humans are the
only animals besides humans that cannot
sleep naturally this realization leads
the doctor to conduct an experiment with
Matilda administering the anesthetic gas
to observe her response miraculously
Matilda succumbs to Slumber meanwhile
Jill finds herself confined in a room
her hands Bound by handcuffs delirium
takes hold of her blurring the line
between reality and her disoriented
State of Mind in this disorienting
situation Murphy the doctor approaches
Jill and inquires about the reason
behind her daughter's ability to sleep
Jill pleads with Murphy urging him to
release Matilda despite his insistence
that the survival of humanity hinges on
her extraordinary gift she reveals that
the Sleep Disorder stems from the same
solar flare that disrupted power
affecting the brains of both humans and
chimpanzees unexpectedly Dodge is
recruited as a guard compelled to
consume stimulants to maintain his
vigilance the woman who could sleep
tragically goes into cardiac arrest and
passes away Jill's mind becomes a
breeding ground for hallucinations as
she envisions Noah her own son posing a
threat an intent on causing harm however
the reality of the situation is far
Grimmer Noah is taken away for further
examination to determine if his brain
holds any differences compared to his
sisters amidst the chaos the soldiers
stationed at the Hub succumbed to
Madness their actions growing erratic as
they discharge their firearms
indiscriminately determined to rescue
her daughter from this volatile
environment Jill embarks on a daring
mission to get together she and Matilda
flee their footsteps echoing in the
corridors as they strive for Freedom
trapped in a hallucinatory state Noah
succumbs to his own Illusions and
inadvertently severs a wire
electrocuting himself witnessing her
son's lifeless body Jill and Matilda
fueled by desperation attempt to revive
him using a defibrillator despite their
desperate efforts Noah remains
motionless yet in a miraculous twist
Noah awakens the following morning
realizing that his apparent demise had
been nothing more than a vivid dream
Noah now enlightened acknowledges the
validity of Jill's concerns about the
Hub recognizing her deep love and need
for her children Matilda 2 grasps a
startling Revelation both she and Noah
possess the ability to sleep because
they had briefly experienced death in a
breathtaking turn of events Jill finds
herself submerged in a lake her life
teetering on the edge as Matilda and
Noah desperately attempt to revive their
mother a flicker of life rekindles
within Jill's being in a moment of
resurgence Jill's eyes open wide and the
screen Fades to the credits click on one
of the videos on your screen right now
[Music]